il s'appelle françois cluzet marion
cotillard valérie bonneton gilles
lellouche benoît magimel ou encore
laurent lafitte
qu'est ce que vous foutez là il nous
avait fait rire puis pleurer sur les
plages de sable du cap ferret cette
année ils reviennent presque au complet
dans nous finirons ensemble la suite des
petits mouchoirs
matip est rien il est là pour se reposer
c'est moi qui m'occupe de tout je vais
pas dormir ici je peux passer ma vie à
dormir avec ses gosses il faut qu'elle
d'armes catherine cet épisode mais non
moi c'est chiant paris police tu veux
pas nous alors là
m
[Musique]
chip charente et vous avec le
réalisateur de cette suite tant attendue
guillaume canet guillaume canet bonjour
bcia alors neuf ans j'allais dire je
suis ravi de recevoir maintenant en
colère ce que vous nous avez fait
attendre neuf ans avant de livrer la
suite des petits mouchoirs ça s'appelle
nous finirons ensemble et à quel moment
vous avez eu le déclic vous a dit c'est
bon je fais cette suite parce que quand
même tous vous demande cette suite vous
la réclament depuis le début ouais ça
s'est fait en deux temps en fait parce
que moi la sortie du film il était pour
moi hors de question de faire une suite
pour j'avais fait un film et puis basta
épuisé pour des pleins de raisons
personnelles est assez dramatique sont
passés à la fin la sortie du film j'ai
pas du tout plus apprécié le succès du
film et j'avais fait un petit roger en
fait pour être très honnête avec le film
et c'est des années plus tard je suis
tombé sur le film à la télé et
j'ai revu la bande comme un spectateur
un peu plus comme un spectateur et je me
suis attaché à nouveau à ses personnages
et puis et puis je me suis j'ai compris
tout d'un coup c'était ça pourrait être
cool de les retrouver je me suis dit
c'est vrai que ça pourrait être sympa de
savoir ce qu'ils sont devenus tous on
était potes pendant 20 ans pour le
budget aurait on est revenu parce qu'il
n'a pas envie de vivre sans toi tu sais
bien comment crois pas que vous
trouverez des technophiles demi heure ça
fait quatre mois après j'ai lellouche y
dit que ce tournage ça a été comme
rentrer dans ses propres souvenirs avec
dix ans de plus à cette suite ça vous a
fait cet effet là aussi
ah ouais totalement il y avait une
émotion très forte même pour les
techniciens qui sont les mêmes parce que
je bosse avec les mêmes techniciens
depuis depuis le début de mes courts
métrages et pour tout le monde voir par
exemple les premières images que l'on a
fait de max de françois cluzet dans la
voiture qui arrive il y avait un truc
très très qui fonce et c'est très
excitant avec françois vous gardez cette
relation complètement à part oui on a
une balle oui on a une relation qui est
qui est basé déjà sur un une expérience
dingue sur ne le dis à personne qui
était un film sur lequel personne ne
voulait qu'on soit ensemble justement et
que et que l'huile
lui même c'était une période de sa vie
où il était plus d'encre euh ouais bien
sûr et le fait qu'on ait outrepassé ça
et qu'on a vécu ce qu'on a vécu sur ce
film et ce qui a suivi derrière avec les
césars avec tout ça ça ne salit y ait
quelque chose
enfin tous que ça oui ça ça crée quelque
chose un lien très fort entre nous alors
on va tous passer dans deux jours et moi
évidemment j'étais censé de barrez il
voulait juste faire une surprise pour
tous les versets mais je ne veux pas
fêter ce d'anniversaire mais dans
lequel des personnages vous retrouvez le
plus max max break c'est quoi ta ble
ment parce que parce que parce que j'ai
le même caractère de merde que lui et
que ma mère et je suis j'ai tendance à
être un peu
where aller à être un peu négative par
moments et je suis solitaire comme lui
tout le temps d'ailleurs besoin des
autres voilà vraiment et le lâcher prise
vous arriver parce que dans le film est
un moment où il a on le voit enfin se
lâcher cercle marsan qui est tout le
temps en contrôlant que lui j'ai faim je
suis complètement comme ça enfin c'est
que ça je si je me suis je me lâche et
je lui ai je dit eto'o alors là ce que
c'est bon là ne rien faire dans la
seconde qui suit je vais aller voir m je
suis en panique parce que je circule pas
totale de pas poser ou ne pas faire un
truc ou deux non je suis pas je suis pas
vraiment quelqu'un je me suis je suis
pas vraiment quelqu'un d'intéressant
finalement non mais j'exagère mais c'est
vrai que j'ai tendance à ne pas savoir
et peut-être qu'avec l'âge ça s'arrange
un peu je commence à savoir un peu plus
me poser et apprécier les bonnes choses
comme les amis par exemple hier soir
c'était mon anniversaire et pour la
première fois j'ai réussi à waimes et à
m'arrêter
c'est quand vous avez des plein de potes
dans un endroit vous parlez avec avec
une avec des personnes mais vous
voudriez être là pour tout le monde
donc en fait vous êtes là pour tout le
monde mais finalement vous avez vu
personne
parler vraiment de mots avec tout le
monde mais personne et là hier soir en
fait je me suis rendu compte qu'on
pouvait rester un quart d'heure vingt
minutes avec quelqu'un a parlé à rigoler
tout ça puis après allez voir quelqu'un
d'autre est resté aussi longtemps
elle faisait plus pris le temps voilà
exactement merci beaucoup guillaume
alors je rappelle nous finirons ensemble
s'ils vous ont manqué autant qu à nous
ils sont tous là benoît magimel gilles
lellouche françois cluzet marion
cotillard et ça sort le 1er mai au
cinéma un grand merci merci à vous